Translation: Good morning.
Translation: My name is Popie-san
Translation: It's been a long time.
Translation: Pew News, welcome!
Hello everyone and good evening.
My name is poopy and welcome to poo news
*contemplation*
Lets just g-go into the news
Sonic killed my dad
Youtube: Oopsy doopsy
Etika... pretty big oopsie.
But most importantly: no PewDiePie oopsie this week!
*Standing ovation*
See if we can hit two weeks *Laughs*
Our first story comes from Sonic.
Sonic the Hedgehog; everyone's favorite little fuzzball....
*Concern*
Besides me of course.
The teaser finally came out--
the trailer I mean of course, of the new Sonic film
And you know, people were nervous that Sonic wasn't going to live up to the expectations.
We didn't read yet know what Sonic was going to look like
What would the size of his peepee be?
A lot of question still unanswered.
There was of course a couple fan versions that looked very promising
People had great ideas, great expectations
and great hope for Sanic
This looks pretty good. That looks like my fan art. *Laughs*
Alright, but without further ado,
We do have a Live First World Reveal Footage Exclusive for the first time here on PewNews®, The Trailer.
Roll it!
[The Sound Of Death]
(JK It is Sonic Music. Its like someone is poking you 4 times a second.)
[Now the actual sound of death]
Wow!
That's amazing!
Finally, they did it!
Finally, a decent Sonic.
I wasn't sure with all the fan stuff that it was gonna live up to the expectations,
But this... I like this . I like this a lot and I could see what they went through here.
They went with a mix of futuristic style,
but still capturing the nostalgia of the old fans.
Thank you Paramount Pictures for doing sonic justice.
[Buzz Implying someone is calling Poopy]
Excuse me. We're getting live reports now saying that that's not the real footage.
Nani desu ka? I can't believe it. Let's watch.
[Heart beat with faint music]
Why do they play-- oh god, what is that? Why does he have human teeth? Why would you do that?
What is this, is this some sort of sick joke?
[Sanic's Voice was cut out for copyright reasons]
Jesus Christ. That's my reaction.
And why is no one talking about the fact that
Here... He can like dodge missiles in real time
But for some reason he can't dodge an arrow to the freaking knee-
Oh arrow to the knee I get it. That's good. That's good. That's a really good joke. *He says sarcastically*
This shot of Jim Carrey in the end made it look cool.
I think I read somewhere- so it's a pretty legit source.
I think I read a comment somewhere that- *laughs*
We only look for the most hard-hitting evidence here on Pew News
Saying that this is just a post credit scene.
Very disappointed, and so was a lot of people.
It has 500,000 dislikes and... I think people just have had enough.
Jeff Fowler, the director or producer, I don't know, tweeted out saying
Jeff Fowler: Thank you for support and the criticism the message is loud and clear.
Jeff Fowler: You aren't happy with the design and you want changes.
Jeff Fowler: It's going to happen, everyone at Paramount and Sega-- Poopy: I don't think everyone, ok?
Jeff Fowler: And Sega are fully committed to making this character the best he can be.
#sonicmovie #gottafixfast
Poopy: You can't fix Sonic he's dead. Ok?
Sonic is dead and we killed him.
There is however one man, one man who can save us all from the suffering
because he's been carrying that suffering,
[Intecified Scream of hatred and rage] King of Sanic: IDIOTS!
For years...
Sammy the Frick is the only one that can save Sonic.
He's been trying to warn us, he tried to tell us for so long.
I mean even myself, I've been advocating for fixing on saving Sonic for years.
I uploaded this video two years ago. Stop ruining Sonic.
You frickin' Fricks, your fantasies can never be quenched.
I wonder how tails is gonna look like?
Oh.
Wow, that's really cool. *He says sarcastically.*
You know, at least the memes is guh- gonna be good for this
I have a feeling it's gonna be a great meme review episode.
*reads meme...* I prefer the real sonic...
I said the real one.
I said the real one!
*whispers* Perfection
I mean this version, would have been better!
This version would have been better!
Hey Paramount Pictures,
I heard that you're looking for a new Sonic and what can I say? I'm your whaman. I can do it.
Next. News.
For those of you who some reason don't know Etica,
he's a streamer and I featured him many times on my channel.
Kid: So guys what I did was, this is my calculator, right.
And I opened it and I was checking...
1 1 3 and 4, and when I turned around, hell.
Etica: WHATTHEF***! WHATTHEF*** Thats crazy!
*laughs* Most people know Etica for his over-the-top reactions and he's become a very popular live streamer
but uh... if you go on Etika's twitter, it's just
It's a lot of nonsense. I don't I don't know what's happening.
I read this wrong, "using Phil." I thought Etika would go on Dr. Phil.
That would be something.
Anyway, Etika live-streamed himself on Instagram and uh...
Someone called the police and he live-streamed it.
Etica: Okay, okay
Etica: Look Look Look. Okay.
Police: *calmly* Turn around, turn around bud.
*then sternly* Turn around.
Etica: Ahhhhh
Etica also went on Keemstar's show, Dramalert, pretty relevant, I've never heard of it
Keem: I know but what would you say to them? Are you actually crazy?
Keem: Are you having a mental breakdown like the cops took you to the...
to the mental place today? What happened?
Etika: Yeah, I went, I became God, and I walked out.
Keem: *In disbelief* That's amazing
That's amazing. *laugh*
Etika also delivered probably the favorite line I've heard in a very very long time
Etika: They can do exactly what they've been doing dreamy creamy Keemy. Just watch.
Poopy: Dreamy creamy Keemy...
Dreamy creamy Keemy ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
So okay. How did the all this happen?
I don't know and I'm not gonna try and force some "Oh, it's so hard to be a streamer and Youtuber"
But he did lose his Youtube account
because I think he's streamed porn
and then he lost his Twitch account, I don't know the order I don't think it's important
but he lost his, he got banned from twitch because he used to slur
He's kind of had this no sh-- to give kind of attitude,
but it's also pretty clear that he's going through a public breakdown
I think anyone can see that and it seems very similar to what we've seen before kind of like with fouseytube
Last year when he did FouseyCon, and it was all about I'm doing all these great things
I don't know anything about psychology and I don't know anything about Etika,
but this is just how I interpret the situation
But it seems to me that Etika needs help and I think that's clear to anyone
except himself
and I know a lot of people are upset with Etika because this is a repeated pattern that he does apparently
And people just want him to get help and they know even if they support him then that won't happen
Everyone is just trying different things to get him to actually get help
But the thing is you can only get help if want to get help
and I think its important Etika realizes that
and I want people to share that sentiment with him to make sure that he actually does
And I actually respect Etika a lot but I would respect him a lot more if he actually did.
Next
News
Susan Wojcicki
Has been in hot water after a leaked footage.
I never thought I would say these words a leaked footage of Susan Wojcicki
talking to Juice Wrld
Let's watch
*inaudible*
Susan: Oh yeah. I...
Susan: I know! How can we help you?
Juice Wrld: ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Susan: You're so talented.
Susan: We've got get your subscriber numbers way up!
*inaudible*
Susan: We're going to make it happen.
Susan: Alright?
Juice Wrld and team: *inaudible*
Susan: We're here, we're here for you.
Susan: However we can, you have no idea. If I-
So this was taken from the no jumper footage
I don't know exactly it's a live stream or something like that
Don't care but a lot of people interpret Susan saying "we're gonna help you"
"We're gonna make your subscribers go way up"
as in YouTube being kind of rigged against creators.
Juice Wrld, obviously, he isn't a youtuber he's a musician.
It caused a lot of uproar, I don't think she knew she was being filmed.
A lot of people saying like "Oh smaller channels are being screwed" yada yada yada
I don't really see it that way personally
I think I'MNOTSUPPOSEDTOGIVEMYOPINION
But it seems more to me like this is CEO talk where you try and butter someone up
It's obviously good for YouTube if an artist like Juice Wrld is on it. Okay?
Or artists in general, it's better for the ecosystem
This kind of talk- I don't think it means anything
I don't think she's gonna go out and do like change the system to help Juice Wrld
I don't think that that's not what he meant here
But a lot of people are interpreting it that way
I just think it's amazing how it Susan gets to meet Juice Wrld
Why don't I get to meet Juice Wrld?
I can't believe both me and Susan listen to angsty teenage Emo rap. Hell, yeah
Susan also posted her update April 30th creator blog
where she followed up on a lot of promises saying about supporting creator artists and artist success.
She talked about meeting with a lot of creators, which we've seen
Wait she met Ethan and Hila? I didn't see that.
and she linked their second channel???
I guess that makes sense
She talks about how they added the self rating system
where creators to themself can rate the video whether its advertising friendly or not
and the thousand channels have it right now
your boy and it works really well and I think this changes the point
that a lot of people made with the whole ad-pocalypse
where there were a few bad videos from these really I don't even know what kind of channels there were
but the whole ad-pocalypse scenario started with ads on white supremacist content
You know how those specific videos can affect everyone on the platform,
It's just kind of ridiculous if you think about it.
So to have youtubers that upload regularly, that doesn't do any bad things
☝️That it's 100% advertiser-friendly and doesn't swear in his videos anymore☝️
☝️And it's just a good rural overall boy in general☝️
☝️And hasn't had any controversy in over a week now☝️
☝️And I think those people are doesn't deserve to get lower ads. Okay, but that's just my opinion☝️
I think it's a step in the right direction. And I'm glad it's happening
They also say that they improve the precision by 25 percent
She also talks about the trending tab and they're saying that they are gonna work on
having it half creators and- or at least half will be actual creators on the trending tab.
So the trending was rigged all along. I knew it
No, she actually explained what I thought for a long time which was
a lot of times a very popular video of mine will not go on trending
and it's just like "Why? Why not?" like...
but the reason why is if all my popular videos got on trending, I would always be I'm trending and just
Take over the trending tab and no one would like that either
So it's basically measured in comparison to my other videos
If one really shoots up that video gets trending but if my all my videos are always doing well,
then there's nothing to stand out from
and I think a lot of people have a misconception about that
They look at the view number and they're like,
"Well this video has this many views and this video has so little views"
"Why is why is this one not trending and then one trending that makes no sense at all"
But maybe...
This is a channel that's always- you can't even see how low I'm pointing right now
but then they get like BAM and then "Oh it's trending!" and then everyone's like "WTF?"
I would and I think- this is just as a game theory
But I think a lot of companies obviously don't upload videos that often
and then maybe they have a trailer for some dumb schmuckabucka video
and all of the sudden that gets more attention so they're like "Oh a trending :D"
Even though it's just a company and it's BS and like screw you Iggy Azalea like I don't like you and that's why
So when creators upload frequently and actually work on YouTube and care about YouTube
they don't get trending because they don't upload videos that shoots up
so therefore it's always just a bunch of mumbo jumbo flumbo schmumbo,
and I think I've spoken pretty eloquently hear about the trending tab
...i don't know what i'm talking about...
☝️That is it for Pew News, thank you guys for watching☝️
☝️check out merch, link in description☝️
It's only one day left if it's not out already. I am so sorry
and sayonara my fellow...
Students, why did I say that? I don't know
What you never played Tuber Simulator?
You know, it's fun, right
I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not
Not convinced yet? Okay
I'll cut you a deal. The game is available for free and that's a great price
[MatPat's Wedding Music]
Please play this UBERLY RELEVANT GAME